qui imagine que la fabrication d'un
parapluie demande plus d'esprit créatif
que de simples savoir faire qui sait que
dans une rue célèbre de poitiers est
installé un atelier de parapluie dont
l'ouverture remonte à un siècle et demi
qui douteraient que les affaires de ce
magasin ont été particulièrement
florissante cette année avec l'hôte
homme plus vieux que nous avons eues et
qui aurait cru qu'une équipe de
reportage tombe en extase devant un
objet apparemment aussi aussi ordinaire
j'ai 80 ans j'ai pu à un moment j'en
ferai mon père était
61 ans ta maison existe oui nous
employons huit personnes personnes et
vous dire quand même que nous avons un
réseau commercial très attendu avec des
représentants mature helmand et je pense
que c'est une entreprise qui se porte
bien
enfin pour l'instant on est très
tributaire du temps mais en fait 10 ans
que cette année on a vraiment pas se
plaint
ils ont que c'est vraiment une
fabrication très spécial très artisanal
qui entièrement fait à la main alors on
à devoir procéder par le le coupage des
brins ensuite taillage et puis
l'assemblement bien sûr les différentes
parties pour fabriquer la peinture
après on a procédé à la coupe
tissu que vous avez ici dans sa carrière
c'est la couleur du poitou et nous avons
fait le montage
alors il te dira sûrement très important
de suivre la mode et la mode
naturellement se fait au départ par des
stylistes à paris qu'il est terminée
tant de tissu ensuite nous avons nos
fabricants de tissus qui passe chez nous
et une choisissons les collections alors
un beau parapluie d'abord avant toute
chose être bien entendu bien tendu sans
creux en tissus naturels mois et puis
est monté aussi dans une très belle
matière pied de mesures pour hommes
et c'est justement cela qui s'en vont se
sauva parisse et savannah les gros tubes
qui font le lit beaujard titre ce serait
de la chouette la tête pour viol ou
lundi au chili à égal
c'est lui qui fournit qui apporteront
ils ont réparé plus d'autre choix
59 ont laissé des canaux
multiples créations il faut le dire et
je pense que c'est un métier qui a
toujours sa place
donc quoi qu'il en soit qui se passe il
faudra toujours des fabricants parapluie
insistera toujours pas rappelé
et
à